for decades la has been home to two
thriving communities of builders the
people who design cars and the people
who build spaceships many of them work
in Polish studios and massive industrial
buildings but the man I'm looking for
works in a place like this
desert how are you good to see you
around I see it sir this is desert
molnar and this is where it keeps his
toys so when we're driving slow we keep
the landing gear down and then once we
hit the freeway and we're in second gear
I'll bring the wheels up so don't freak
out
does her used to fly planes in the
airforce then he built rockets and
rocket powered cars he's been in some
bands
he's been rich he's been poor he's a
free spirit who does whatever he wants
like a lot of Angelenos dezer often
finds himself stuck for hours on the
freeway wishing there was a way to rise
up and escape from the concrete prison
this is my first attempt at a flying car
the flying car as development has often
been mired in the idea that you have to
make something for everybody and that
you have to dumb it down so that it's a
consumer product to cut a few seconds
off of somebody's commute
I don't have the objective about
creating ubiquity da Vinci did one copy
of the Mona Lisa and it wasn't for
everybody and it wasn't like you had to
make 500 of them but it still has value
and I see a lot of the machines that
have been made as art pieces and I think
what they need is a gallery right now to
help drive the interest in the
development to drum up that interest
desert soon plans to start a flying car
racing league in the Mojave Desert
there's a long-standing marriage between
LA and the Mojave it's in LA where
engineers go about their day jobs and
fancy offices and it's in the Mojave
where the folks who can never stop
experimenting go to try out their ideas
on the weekends
Mojave is sort of what it's like the
playground for the testbed it's about
the people you want to meet as opposed
to people that you don't need its those
are the freaks you know that that matter
to me are the ones that want to go out
then take their 300 mile an hour jet car
out on a Saturday afternoon
yeah I'll see you at the free okay you
can join the club
Mojave is about a two-hour drive into
the California desert from Los Angeles
and most of that time is spent staring
at bumpers God is traffic SOT deal with
this and yes
the flying car seems like a great idea
but as we made our way out into the
inventer Badlands the reality of zipping
across the desert in a loose assembly of
metal pipes and good intentions felt
somewhere between stupid and terrifying
the truth though is that much of this
technology is tried and true the first
part of deserts flying car plan hinges
on this gyrocopter
these types of vehicles have been flying
since the 1920s they're cheap relatively
easy to build and pretty reliable
instead of running on a motor the
propeller gets its lift from the wind as
the craft goes forward
incredible that is crazy you should get
like this totally different perspective
if the engine cuts out the copter would
just flutter down to the ground like a
leaf falling out of a tree my adrenaline
was pumping right before we took off but
you know like the second we were in the
air I mean you just there's a lot to see
it's pretty here I sort of forget about
at all yeah and as you saw I mean
obviously there's we can land anywhere
out here so it's a perfect place the
gyrocopter takes care of the up part of
the flying car puzzle but you still need
something to deal with the rows for that
deser has this slick concept vehicle the
goal is to marry the two and have
something that turns just about any road
into a runway when that happens okay if
that happens the select few willing to
give it a go will taste freedom while
the rest of us rot on the 405 I think
that the reality is that a lot of people
in this world like to have some kind of
an advantage in life no matter what
they're doing whether it's a bigger
stereo or a you know a swimming pool at
their house but the reality is that in
nature all birds can walk all bugs that
fly have legs and they can fold their
wings up on their back they survive in
different environments because they've
adapted to get through them to say that
we're going to spend 40 billion hours a
year in the United States sitting in
traffic saying that well no one will
ever have one of these I don't really
care if that's the party line
you can make something that will allow
you to escape this ridiculous aunt line
of eternity
you
you